c'est un secret bien gardé un coin de
campagne sur la Rive-Sud du
Saint-Laurent tout près de la métropole
trait d'union entre boire noir et
Châteauguay 7 km de côte jalonné de
résidence de luxe de qui est privé sur
un vaste plan d'eau terrain de jeu idéal
pour les passionnés de sport nautique
mais la ville de Léry est surtout connue
pour son golf qui attire les adeptes de
toute la région
[Musique]
et alors que la campagne électorale
amorce son dernier droit elle s'y met
aussi sur le verre
[Musique]
moi je crois que les jeunes partis ont
des très bonnes idées mais moi je suis
pas bien que la CAQ mérite un autre
mandat
qui arrive de faire sa web je reviens
mes vieilles habitudes si on veut là
j'ai de la misère encore à faire mon
choix c'est c'est dur
les électeurs de l'iris sont un peu le
reflet des intentions de vote ailleurs
au Québec la ville est d'ailleurs
représentative à plus d'un titre car les
défis les problèmes vécu ici sont loin
d'être uniques ici ça va être la rue
Arlon Victor qui est un ancien
professeur d'école
les riz est en pleine transformation une
nouvelle école un nouveau quartier
résidentiel donc c'est ce quartier comme
vous le voyez c'est
200 nouvelles maisons éventuellement 200
autres maisons derrière là-bas une
fierté mais en même temps un casse-tête
pour le maire de la petite ville
confronté simultanément aux problèmes de
pénurie de logement et d'étalement
urbain des enjeux selon lui absents de
la campagne je laisse sur ma faim un peu
qu'est-ce que j'ai de besoin pour le
même municipalité
les parties semblent pas le l'offrir
que le sentiment d'urgence qui l'anime
ne semble pas partager par tous
l'environnement pour s'en occuper tout
de suite et maintenant c'est aujourd'hui
c'est pas demain notre vision une
question au cœur des préoccupations ici
alors que la moitié de la ville est
privée des goûts et d'aqueduc bonjour
madame Odet
c'est le cas d'Eve Mario dette forcée de
bois de l'eau en bouteille car celle de
son puits est impropre à la consommation
si il y avait quoi que ce soit qu'on
pouvait faire de plus que si vous
demandez je le conçois pas encore quand
2022 à 20 quelques kilomètres de la
ville de Montréal ce serait juste normal
d'avoir l'eau pendant 2022 de l'eau
propre dans son robinet mais aussi dans
son environnement un besoin essentiel
qui guidera le vote de cette jeune mère
de famille moi c'est primordial qu'il
faut que ça se fasse c'est pas normal
que des gens rejettent leurs égouts dans
le lac en 2022 la ville vient d'agrandir
son installation de traitement des eaux
usées elle a aussi au projet d'offrir
égout et à queduc à tous les citoyens
des infrastructures essentielles et
pourtant impossible à réaliser sans
l'aide de Québec les coûts sont
exorbitants sous alentours de 65
millions minimum notre budget annuel est
quatre points 9 millions
donc c'est c'est les discute donc si le
gouvernement nous appuie pas nous aide
pas on ne peut pas faire ce projet seul
et les conséquences du statu quo dépasse
largement les limites de la municipalité
les fosse septiques qui sont désuètes
maintenant souvent ils polluent non
seulement que la nappe phréatique les
puits mais aussi le lac et le fleuve un
discours qui rejoint bien des citoyens à
Léry car comme Eve-Marie c'est
l'environnement qui a poussé beaucoup de
gens à s'installer ici on a la chance
d'être sur le bord du fleuve qui est à
mon avis un des joyaux du Québec on doit
le préserver moi j'aimerais ça qu'on
parle davantage des changements
climatiques parce que d'une part c'est
effectivement c'est ce qui va avoir un
impact sur nous sur les générations
futures c'est pas la priorité ça devrait
être ça selon moi alors que les
électeurs ici se sentent courtisés par
tous les partis le maire croit que les
rives à conserver son statut de ville
baromètre mais il n'exclut pas les
surprises le gouvernement de monsieur
Legault
a probablement un support ici à ville de
Léry mais encore une fois est-ce que
c'est tous les citoyens c'est difficile
à dire à Liri parce que Québec Solidaire
est là et les jeunes sont là puis
l'environnement est important énormément
le 3 octobre si les électeurs de l'iris
risquent de suivre encore une fois les
vents dominants leur vote pourrait aussi
révéler les prémices devant de
changement qui place l'environnement en
tête des priorités